[Music]
all right let's run out to Jasper
Indiana and talk to Shannon what's up
Shannon hi how we
doing I am so nervous I didn't think I
was but wow okay don't listen one day
I'm just gonna have a show of all the
people I dated in high school and middle
school not all of them just some of them
and they're going to tell some stories
and then no one's ever going to be
nervous again I'm just a goofball of the
podcast man I'm glad you're with us
what's up okay so I've been listening to
the show for probably a year now
and I have a question that I can't seem
to answer myself and it keeps popping up
and okay I don't know what you always
talk about in
your everything what you want your life
to look like what you want your picture
to be what you picture what you want
Etc how do you find what you want I
don't know what I want I know what I
don't
want but how do you strive for a life
that you want because I could dream all
day long but it's not going to be
realistic why
not because I'm not a millionaire living
on a beach with no responsibilities
because all my nannies and housekeepers
take care of everything so if you were
to um actually go there in your fantasy
life this is a great question by the way
um and not in your fantasy like not that
life but like your fantasy life like is
that what you would
want no to sit on a beach and literally
do nothing while people just handed you
drinks because the research tells me
that would be amazing for about four
days but how do you set realistic once
near your picture realistically in your
own daily life why are you I I I'll
answer that question because I think
there's some really there's some really
simple ways to get there but I'm I'm
hung up on your hang up on the the word
realistic because everyone goes to work
and you get home and you have two hours
with the kids with eating and homework
and bedtime and then before you know it
it's 9:00 and it's like wow that
escalated where did that go um okay I
guess we'll just unwind and do it all
again
tomorrow like the way you just describe
that sounds
miserable well that makes me
sad well I I think you're somebody who
is so so fun to be around is that
true like do people like hanging out
with you yes okay and I think you're
really talented ented
at hiding from yourself is that fair
very yes so and listen I can tell by the
tone of your voice because here's why in
counseling they train us that everything
is data okay so if somebody's talking to
you and you find yourself like you keep
getting distracted distracted distracted
there's a chance
that that's that person experiences that
with everyone they talk to that everyone
they talk to is just bored out of their
mind and so a good counselor will say
hey to people say you're boring or
people struggle to pay attention to you
you instantly I'm drawn to
you okay like your vocal inflection you
sound fun I I I guarantee you people w't
hang out with you okay so my question is
this why are you hiding
from or a better word is why are you
settling for
this like what has happened to bring you
to this moment where you're you think
the phrase this is just the way this is
going to be
how do you
balance your
responsibilities as a wife a mom an
employee with fun because you know
what's
fun that that a lot of things are fun
rattle them
off because I don't believe you rattle
them off what's
fun well they are fun but then you throw
the kids in the family ah see there you
go this is just the way this is what is
fun for Shannon and I'm I'm not picking
on you I'm heading somewhere with this I
like I mean I have fun at the
concerts
eating snacks with my friends in our
pajamas you know but it's so hard
to balance everything yes and I will
tell you that balance is a 100% LIE
there's no such
thing no such thing it's a complete and
utter
manufactured um
lie it's a marketing sluggan that's been
sold particularly to wives increasingly
towards men but for the last hundred
years particularly to
wives um that you can do it all have it
all feel it all exper erience it all
love it all and if you're off in any of
those it's because you need a new Gadget
a new toy a new thing or because you
suck and just need to get better and
it's nonsense it's just
nonsense so here's I'm I'm gonna start
with this and then I'll actually get to
your actual question
okay okay um the greatest gift you can
give your husband the greatest
gift is
having something that you're truly
passionate about that you're plugged
into that you love that lights you
up the greatest if you don't know what
that is we'll get there I I'll show you
I'll show you how to get there the
greatest thing you can give your
kids is you having friends that you go
to concerts
with not all the time and abandon your
children that's not what I'm talking
about but people that you go hang out
with people that bring you Joy and
laughter and make you feel
alive that's the greatest gift because
that makes you non-anxious that makes
you non- electric or in your case that
makes you non
dymic this just the way this is lowlevel
depression all the time yes right
yes and the kids absorb that your
husband absorbs that and I'm just going
to throw something out there you can say
no you're kind of missing the boat here
your husband tries to get it back
through
sex or through some sort of Adventure or
he has created a life of his
own the lad okay your kids either bury
their faces in electronics or they try
to cure you through hey Mom hey Mom hey
Mom hey
Mom
yeah okay so here is a great way I think
you're on to it you're so close to it
you're looking past it you ever have
like your kid like is like Mom where's
the fork and you're like right there and
they're like where and their hand is one
centimeter from it that's you okay I
don't want you to think that you're
malfunctioning you're broken or you have
a 100 miles to go you don't you're right
there tell me some things in your life
you're sick of that you don't
want that's a long list give me five of
them rattle them off top to your top of
top of your mind doesn't matter whose
feelings you think you need to protect
you've been protecting people's feelings
your whole freaking life and just for
this one call just
stop tell me what you're sick
of being boring being bored at home okay
just the everybody just being so grouchy
okay um is everybody mostly your
husband all all three my husband and
kids okay
I'm so excited to go home and you open
the door and it's just like whoa
yeah what else what are you tired
of I don't
know what do you not want you started
the call like I don't know what I do
want but I know what I don't want what
do you not
want I just want people to be fun to be
around it's it the day doesn't have to
end
at 9 or 10 or whatever but it does in
real life because you have to it up and
do it all over
again I don't want a non-ending party
but I just feel like
everyone's down
okay
that's silly no it's listen what you
just described in a beautiful
way I would suggest most of America's
experiencing
it almost everybody is just sick of
it and if we go all the way to the halls
of politicians nobody will tell us what
they're for they will only tell us why
everyone else is
awful and in are all the way down to our
local communities nobody will do
anything but yell and scream and fight
and be angry and inside our homes
everyone's just not happy and I don't
mean happy in fireworks and marshmallows
and you know and cigarettes when you're
in high school I'm talking about happy
like they don't like the lives they've
created for themselves right yes then
they're grouchy about
it okay you that's a perfect word
everyone is Oscar the Grouch and so
here's the exercise okay reverse it it
it I I envy people who can just be like
I want this and I'm going to go get
this that's just not how I
work in my life I got sick of being
unable to
sleep and I got sick of my wife and my
kids having to create a life away from
me because I was so anxious and electric
all the
time and so in this situation I'm your
husband I'm so sick of being so grouchy
in my own home how do I stop this I
didn't know what I wanted but I knew I
had to stop feeling like this and so
reverse engineering is a great way to
find out you're not that far off but I
want you to spend some time actually
writing down what am I tired of in my
own
home because if you have a house
surrounded by grouchy people and you are
you're natural inclination is laughter
and joy and let's go do something fun or
my gosh the kids are in bed let's close
the door and peel the wallpaper off this
place it I just want to I got to do some
work honey I and you feel trapped in
your own
home then your body just shuts the whole
thing down right yes okay let's reverse
engineer it let's write down and let's
be honest for probably the first time
and you said there's a long list I want
you to make that long list tired of
everybody being so bored and grouchy I'm
tired of not having enough money for
this I'm tired of I'm just can't handle
write that crap
down and then I want you to make a
column that's one column and then next
to it you can do an Excel spreadsheet if
you're a super nerd or you can do it on
a yellow pad if you're from The 14th
Century like me and I want you just to
draw a line to the things that you can
actually do something
about okay so that's step one what of
these things that I want to be different
in my life can I actually do something
about okay that's step one here's step
two the more they
things the more it ends up in accusation
land so you take your husband out for
breakfast or for lunch like I always
tell everybody to do and you say I need
you to stop doing this and stop doing
this and stop doing this well now you
started throwing punches and he has to
he has to swing back or he has to Turtle
up and just take
it okay so I don't want you to start
with you need to do a you need to do B
you need to do
c i want you to start with something
completely different and I've talked
about this a little bit publicly and I
need to do a better job of it
when my wife sat across the table from
me and this is years ago and we were
deciding are we like grown-ups are we
still going to be married like let's be
adults is this is this where we how is
this where this thing
ends and we both agreed no this is where
this thing's going to restart and re be
reimagined but when we did that we
started with something that is very not
me and is very not her we started with
our feelings
first how do I want this house to feel
when I walk into
it and then from the feeling part what
has to be true and so I said I want to
feel safe in my own body in my own house
because I grew up in the house of a
homicide detective and at any moment it
could all come down right I wanted a
couple of acres and I wanted a huge
garden and I wanted to become a better
Hunter does that mean I'm a little bit
of a prepper a little bit chill Shannon
right but my wife said cool so here's
what has to happen for them that we have
to make x amount of
dollars which means for a season we have
to sacrifice X Y and Z for that to
happen when we had that conversation and
we had a road map it didn't start with
you need to make more money or I need to
work more it started with I want to feel
safe and my whole body went
whoosh and both of us said we want when
we open our front door we want our house
to feel um or actually when we come up
we have a long driveway into the woods I
mean there is Banjo a plan out there and
you turn into our long driveway my wife
said I want to feel like I'm coming home
and I said when we open the front door I
want it to feel like laughter and warmth
so what has to be true she said when you
get home before me will you turn the
porch lights on so I can see him coming
from half a mile away
done for it to feel warm and full of
laughter the house can't be full of
dishes John you can't have piles all
over the freaking house can't be dirty
clothes just dry dropped from the
opening to the front door all the way to
back
done see what I'm
saying so the question is sitting down
with your husband saying what has to be
true in this home that you don't have to
feel so
grouchy or what what has to be true in
your life that makes you have to treat
our kids like this treat me like this
treat the sacredness of our home like
this and we're going to start with
feelings first does that make sense
yes why does that scare you so
much because my husband has a lot of
ability to shut it
down without
proceeding as adult yeah so here's the
problem you have to make space where
your husband won't come along for the
ride and I want to challenge
you to tell him I I me and our
kids cannot
accept what may become verbally
abusive we
can't I'm asking you not to shut down
when we have this conversation today do
you promise me
that and if he says uhuh I ain't doing
that then you know in your heart you got
bigger issues in your marriage right
right do you have bigger issues your
marriage our biggest issue is
communication
okay I think this is a great way to
begin to get everybody on the same page
especially as we enter into a new
year and so when you sit down and say
hey let's go on a long date a two or
three hour date preferably in the
morning because people aren't
exhausted I want you to make a lot of
eye
statements here's what I want to feel
like in my
home here's what I want our sex life to
be like here's what I want my
relationship with our kids to be like I
would love to hear from you H
husband what do you want this to feel
like and then how do we combine these
things and how do we get
there and if he shuts down and says this
is stupid I ain't doing this my oh my
gosh if you would just shut up then none
of this would H if that's the response
then you tell them I'm going to go see a
counselor this breakfast is over because
this isn't working and I'm not saying
leave him I'm saying you've got much
bigger issues in your marriage because
you have a man a husband who has no
interest in loving his wife you have a
man or a husband who has no interest in
building a long-term relationship with
his kids you have a husband who is
interested in in being a whiny
brat and husbands if you're listening to
this and you are a
grouch stop fix it get the healing you
need oh when I work hard I get h no your
kids don't deserve that your wife
doesn't deserve that
stop so Shannon my guess is there's a
much bigger fish to fry here but I think
it's an amazing exercise for you to
start I'm going to send you a copy of
building a non-anxious life my brand new
book I want you to use it as a road map
in my home these six PL these six
stages these six
choices where are we
off actually I'm going to send you two
ask your husband if he'll read it with
you so I'm just asking you to love me
enough just to read this book with me
and I want us to use these six daily
choices as a road map to bring peace
into our house and tell them I love you
so much that I want more for you in your
life than you just to be exhausted and
grouchy and not even like being in your
own
home I want that to be different do
you thank you so so much for the call
Shannon I'm grateful for you I'm
grateful for
you